welcome to the press conference
following the EU Republic of Korea vtc
that just ended now may I ask your
attention for the joint press release
which we just put online and I'm going
to give the floor now first to the EU
council president mashaykhina and shaker
good morning everyone I am pleased that
we could speak today with president moon
about important issues for both the EU
and the Republic of Korea this year we
celebrate the 10th anniversary of the EU
ability of Korea strategic partnership
this partnership is anchored in the
values of democracy human rights and
rule of law and our desire to find
common answers to global challenges and
today we had the occasion to focus on
three key areas the first one is traffic
19 and the economic recovery the seventh
one is the EU South Korea relationship
and the third one is the regional and
international issues
our goal is clear we want to be a
stronger player in Asia about travel 19
we commend president moon successful
handling of the pandemic in South Korea
and we will continue to share
information and best practices to
bolster our mutual preparedness and
response capacities and we support
reviewing the W issues handling of the
crisis at the right time will agree that
multilateralism and solidarity are key
to overcoming the pandemic we discussed
how to deepen our cooperation on
research and development of vaccines and
medicines any vaccine should be a global
common route to leave X and wha
c'mon say Don so sultry no pain so
Mobile is Avignon some the new partner
at a national level so see Lucas room de
Borda latest on the Holland's economic
tomorrow construe more resilient
multiple do have a video CD present
receive consider later a La Jolla
Cardinal journey from the jihad it
delivered altered item version travel
the European and Korean economies rely
on openness and we will continue to
support free and fair and fair trade and
fight protectionism will also enhance
our strategy autonomy we agreed under
need to assist the most vulnerable
especially in the developing countries
including on debt relief ten years ago
in 2010 we took our corporation our
operation to the next level strategic
partnership today relationship is strong
from economy and trade to research
energy and dental information we trade
over 90 billion euros a year and use the
largest investor in South Korea not
recuperation
effandi savate trans actor la caja de la
croix de libération de Letran solo
participation ads operation the session
dotrice
new 7 location adelmo the cellular
licinia to the lake tahoe major
deviation in the world
a female la volunteer criminal don't
proceed occupation villa de la langue de
ferran sector tell ladies monkey
multiplication digital lock relativity
occasion the drama war torrente el
equipo y Porsche so my own person
innovative REO civilization la boda
cetacean centrale important porn or open
komodo krys mobile is a poor combat
receiver attack yamato
led deformation zone the - polymer del
democratic Oh Tennyson telmo attack
religion rapid renewal Hoffman sweat at
an actor and a solo plan intl sweeten
active Eden more honest projective
on a sec - no sweat on 11 D Coppola
Darren Taylor Machado pay a disability
natural more latisha no penicillin a
table d0x prima
no Dante two servos oh yeah avec une
autre de saucé de tránsito de valle de
new Jean Jacques Oh issued no lazy for
de Cristo moon of travel a very solution
to accomplish the stability a prison
security Agua Dulce
lock oh please the negotiation ultra
lack of a donor literally I would like
to add that the EU remains committed to
complete verifiable and irreversible
dismantlement of North Korea's nuclear
and other weapons of mass destruction
and ballistic missile programs full
implementation of UN sanctions by the
international community remains crucial
we also touched on the situation in
other parts of the world like in Aaron
Ukraine and of course will touch on the
situation in Hong Kong the travis 19
pandemic has reaffirmed the strategic
importance of this relationship and we
look forward to a physical meeting in
seoul as soon as the situation allows
thank you thank you so much
shall i would like to also to thank
president moon for discussions this
morning indeed and times of
unprecedented global health crisis we
need countries to come together to work
together and to achieve together it was
important to exchanging the experiences
and best practices with the Republic of
Korea corresponding to the pandemic so
even more so given their very innovative
and very
successful approach to slowing down the
pandemic one important aspect that we
discussed is the need for mutual support
in the supply of medical products as
well as concrete cooperation on research
and development of Diagnostics vaccines
and therapeutics and increasing the
manufacturing capacity the Republic of
Korea made a very generous pledge to the
coronavirus Global Response initiative
back in May and this time the Prime
Minister Jang delivered a clear
political statement during the global
event on Saturday so this shows that
Korea has sent and is sending a very
strong message to the world as a
reliable partner in this common cause
the European Union and the Republic of
Korea have a strategic partnership so
concretely this means that the intensity
and the level of our cooperation is
among the highest that we have with any
country in the world the cooperation is
particularly relevant when it comes to
relaunching sustainable inclusive and
resilient economies we have a free trade
agreement that is providing concrete
proof of the mutual benefits of open
trade to our businesses and to our
citizens indeed our trade in goods past
90 billion last year and interestingly
the trade in services reached nearly 20
billion also so this shows the intensity
of trade relation we have between two
both regions of course we discussed with
president moon how to ensure that our
trade relations keep getting stronger in
order to reach their full potential a
few topics where we put emphasis on for
example we put emphasis on the
importance of climate action as a
fundamental part of a sustainable
economic recovery it is interesting to
see that
Korea has its Korean green deal they'll
call it like that so we discussed how to
manage the green transition encouraging
also others to do the same and of course
to deliver on our perspective on our
respective commitments under the Paris
agreement so the question for both sides
is now how to deliver on our goal for
carbon neutrality and as the Republic of
Korea referring to its own Korean Green
Deal was very strong on their ideas we
can count on their full support and
cooperation in its implementation we
hope that this can be an inspiration to
others in the region a good example
leading by example is over the best the
present crisis has also shown the
potential of the digital transformation
for our economies and societies so we
are both convinced that investing in
clean and digital technologies will help
us to create lasting jobs and better
growth we agreed with president moon to
advance our cooperation in this area as
well as on data protection we also
looked upon our strong cooperation
collaboration in research and innovation
we are looking forward to further
enhancing this cooperation under the
EU's so-called Horizon Europe program so
all well known so while we look forward
to have our regular summit in Seoul at
the earliest possible time today I think
was an important moment to reaffirm our
joint commitment on working together
across all the areas that have been
touched now in the press conference and
above that thank you thank you madam
president we'll take a couple of
questions please switch on your cameras
and raise the blue hand like we are used
to now we're going to Robin Emmet from
Reuters Reuters can you hear us Robin
yes very well thank you thank you for
this question so my question is that
China's national parliament has now
passed the security law for Hong Kong
and can I get the your reaction from
both presidents please thank you very
much thank you indeed this low risks
seriously under manage the high degree
of autonomy of Hong Kong and having a
detrimental effect on the Independence
of the judiciary and the rule of law and
we draw this decision yes I can just on
the same topic we are aware that the
Standing Committee of China's National
People's Congress has adopted new
national security legislation for Hong
Kong indeed we've made clear on several
occasions including in our direct
contacts last week with the Chinese
leadership the new legislation does not
conform with Hong Kong's basic law nor
with China's international commitments
both in terms of adoption procedure and
inceptions
so we're very clear on that topic that
is for us very critical and we're
seriously concerned about it thank you
going to Laurence Norman from The Wall
Street Journal Lawrence can you hear us
yes you have to unmute your sound
Lawrence we can't hear me can you hear
me now
yes we can great sorry about that thank
good morning thanks to the programs for
doing this and I'm afraid I need to go
back to Hong Kong a question for madam
has been you you said last week that
there would be very serious consequences
if 9 and moved ahead with the national
security law Hong Kong is it not time
now to spell out what those very
negative consequences will be on the
relation and the question for president
Michele could you give a sustained of
what president moon said about the peace
process with the north after the blowing
up of the of the liaison office did you
get the sense from him that the peace
process was unraveling or did he read
events in a different way thank you
madam president
yes so indeed this law risk seriously
undermining the high degree of autonomy
of Hong Kong and having a detrimental
effect on the Independence of the
judiciary and the rule of law and in
line with assurances that China gave in
the past the existing rights and
freedoms of Hong Kong residents must be
fully protected we have indeed
consistently said that China would risk
wearing negative consequences if it went
ahead with this law including for
business confidence
China's reputation public perception in
Hong Kong and internationally many
across Europe including in the European
Parliament have made similar stance
statements so we remain in touch with
our international partners on this
matter and we'll pay carefully attention
on to how to respond to about about the
Korean Peninsula indeed we are we are
concerned because we feel that we face
the last days the last weeks more
tensions in this part of the world in
this region you know that president moon
is personally very committed in order to
support a diplomatic process in order to
reach more stability in the in the
region and we consider also that is
important that the United States and
North Korea we establish a process of
political dialogue we are also ready to
play a stronger role in Asia and also in
this part of the world and I've informed
president moon that the European Union
we are also ready to
more committed in favor of a peace
process of more stability in the inner
region thank you taking the last
question now by Stuart Lao can you hear
a Stuart hi yes so called Madam
President just now you mentioned it in
Parliament resolution on Hong Kong a
couple of weeks ago give us an idea
whether the Commission makes any follow
up actions to the suggestions made by
the European Parliament and for
President Michelle and the US has
already introduced defense equipment and
for exports to Hong Kong do you think
European countries should follow suit
thank you we will indeed carefully
assess we're in close cooperation with
the European institutions this has to be
done with care and this is the process
we are in know we had the occasion a few
days ago to express our grave concerns
because we knew that there was this
possibility that they would vote this
new legislation now they took the
decision to vote this legislation and we
have expressed what we think about that
and I repeat that we deplore this
decision and of course we will need also
a strong coordination with all the
Member States in order to see what we
will do in the near future thank you
very much this concludes our press
conference of today please may I invite
you to read the joint press release
which was published on our websites
thank you